I know nobody then well I mean with  pants like that you're gonna be the life  of the party in no time yeah thanks  they're orange dude this is your song  bro  I'm waiting for you somewhere  all the dudes in the bucket oh my god I  love this song here doing my phone guy  we're gonna dance may I have this middle  school dance absolutely  I don't know I really like the idea that  I could like create something new baby  yeah it's good no it's great  this is where we win by the way  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  bent  Hey what are you doing here I live here  what are you doing here  I had live in the building I didn't know  you wore glasses yeah yeah it's just to  see nice I like oh thanks  this could be fun  [Music]  [Music]